The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
So welcome to the next
lecture about exploiting
buffer overflow.
So today, what we're
going to do is,
we're going to finish up our
discussion about baggy bounds
and then we're going
to move on to a couple
of other different techniques
for protecting its buffer
overflows.
Then we're going to talk
about the paper for today,
which is the blind return
oriented programming.
So if you were like me when
you first read that paper
you kind of felt like you were
watching like a Christopher
Nolan movie at the beginning.
It was kind of like
mind blowing right.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to actually step through
how some of these gadgets
work right.
And so hopefully
by the end, you'll
be able to understand all this
sort of high tech chicanery
that they're doing in the paper.
So first of all,
like I said, let's
just close up with the
baggy bounds discussions.
Let's go through a very
simple example here.
So let's say that we're going
to define a pointer called P.
And let's say that
we're going to give it
allocation size of 44.
Let's also assume that the
slot size equals 16 bytes OK.
So what's going to happen when
we do this malloc up here?
So as you know, the
baggy bounds system
is going to pad that allocation
out to the next power of two,
right.
So even though we've only
allocated 44 bytes here,
we're actually going to allocate
64 bytes for this pointer
up here.
And so also note too, this
is the slot size is 16.
How many bounds tables entries
are we going to create?
Well we're going to create
the allocation size, which
in this case 64, divided by
the slot size, which is 16.
So in this case we'll create
four different bounds table
entries for this
thing right here.
Each one of those
entries is going
to be set to the log of
the allocation size, which
in this case is
going to be 6 right.
Because the allocation
size is 64, OK?
So, so far so good.
Then we're going to define
another pointer called q
and we're going to set
it equal to p plus 60.
So what happens when we do this?
Well note that
strictly speaking,
this access is out
of bounds, right.
Because this was only
allocated 44 bytes of memory,
but of course the way
that baggy bounds works
is that it will actually allow
axises that are out of bounds,
if they stay within
that baggy bounds.
So even though
strictly speaking,
the programmer probably
shouldn't have done this,
this is actually
going to be OK, right.
We're not going to raise any
flags or anything like that.
Now let's say that
the next thing we do
is we need to find another
pointer, which is going to be
set equal to q plus 16 right.
Now this is actually going
to cause an error, right.
Because now q is at an offset
of 60 plus 16, which equals 76.
So this is actually 12
bytes away from the end
of that baggy bounds.
OK?
And that's actually greater
than half a slot away.
All right, so if you remember
the baggy bounds system will
actually throw a hard
synchronous error if you
get beyond 1/2 a slot from
the edge of that baggy bounds.
So this will actually
cause the program to fail.
This will actually make it stop.
Now let's imagine that we
didn't have this line of code
in the program, OK.
So we had these two, but
we don't have this one.
So what if we instead
of doing this line,
did something that
looks like this.
We declare another
pointer, let's call it s,
and we set it equal to q plus 8.
Now in this case,
the pointer is going
to be at 60 plus 8, which equals
68 bytes away from p, right.
So this is only four bytes
beyond that baggy bound.
So this will not
actually cause an error.
Even though it is strictly
speaking, out of bounds.
What we will do here though,
is set that high order
bit on the pointer, right.
So that if anyone
subsequently tries
to dereference this
thing, it's going
to cause a hard
fault at that point.
And then let's say, the
final thing that we do
is we declare another
pointer t, which
is going to equal s minus 32.
So what happens here
is that essentially we
brought this pointer t, it
is now back in bounds, right.
So what that means is that
even though this guy was out
of bounds, now we sort of going
back to the original allocated
region, that we originally
created up here.
So as a result, t will not
have that high order bit step
and so you can dereference T
and everything will be fine.
So does this all make sense?
This should be fairly
straightforward.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the difference
between r and s, how
would you know that r is--
or how does the program know
that r is 1/2 the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So note
that, like up here,
when we create r you
can basically interpose,
we get an instrumented
code that's
going to be working at all
of these pointer operations.
So basically we can tell is that
we know where P is going to be.
I'm sorry, we know
where q is going to be.
And we know that q is
within those baggy bounds.
And so when we do
this operation here,
the instrumentation
of baggy bounds
adds and we're able
to say, aha, well I
know where that source
formula is coming from.
And then if you look
at this offset here,
you determine it's more than a
1/2 slot away from slot side.
So basically what
you think about is
that as we're doing
these pointer operations,
and looking and saying is how
are you going out of bounds,
have you gone out of
bounds, yes or no.
At some point you're going
to have some operation that's
going to involve a pointer
that is either in bounds
within the baggy bounds and
then some thing over here that
makes it go out of bounds.
So at that moment,
right when that happens,
that's how we know that
something chicanerous has
arisen.
All right so, hopefully
that should all make sense.
And so this is very
briefly a review
of the homework question.
So hopefully you can understand
this and our homework question
should be pretty
easy to understand.
So we have a character pointer
the malloc had 256 bytes to it,
Then we declare a
character pointer
q, that is equal to
that pointer plus 256
and then we essentially try
to dereference this pointer.
So what's going to happen?
Well note that this is an
exact power too, right.
So there's not actually any
bagginess in the bounds, right.
So when we do this right here,
this makes q point to one
pass the end of
those baggy bounds.
So just like in this
example up here,
this line is actually fine,
but it will cause the high bit
to be set in q, right.
So when you come down
here and reference it,
then everything
blows up and it's
time to call in your
insurance agent.
So pretty straightforward?
OK so, that's
basically two examples
that you can flavor for
how baggy bounds works.
As I mentioned in
the last lecture,
you don't actually have to
instrument every pointer
operation, if you can use static
code analysis to figure out
the particular set of
pointer operations is safe.
I'll defer further
discussion of some
of the static
analysis [INAUDIBLE],
but suffice it to say
that you don't always
have to have all this bit
wise arithmetic that you
have in some of the cases
that we've examined before.
And so another question
that came up a lot in Piazza
was, how does baggy bounds
ensure compatibility
with these preexisting,
non-instrumented libraries,
right.
And so the Piazza idea behind
how baggy bounds does that
is, that when baggy bounds
initializes the bounds tables,
they set all the entries
to be that bound of 31.
So when we read
the bounds table,
each entry represents
2 to the power
of that entry, the size of
that particular pointer.
So by initializing
all those bounds
of 31, what this allows
us to do is automatically
assume that each pointer
from [INAUDIBLE] the code
is going to have the
largest bound possible, 2
raised to the 31.
So let me just give you a
very simple example here
that will hopefully make
this a little clearer.
So let's say that this
over here is the memory
space that we lose for heap.
This is simple example,
let's suppose that basically
what this memory space
[INAUDIBLE] two components.
This is the heap, that is out
by the unistrumented code.
And then let's suppose
that down here we
have the heat that is allocated
by the instrumented code.
So what's baggy
bounds going to do?
So remember, baggy bounds has
this notion of a slot size,
right.
So basically the
slot size is 16,
you only have entry
for every sort
of slot of size 16 over here.
So basically the bounds
table in this case,
you can think of being
set up into three
places, sorry two places.
So initially all of the
bounds table, all the entries
are initialized to 2 to the
30-- or sorry, to the 31.
But then eventually
as the instrument code
runs it's actually going
to use the baggy bounds
algorithm to set these
values for whatever
should be appropriate for that
particular [INAUDIBLE], right.
So what ends happening
is that if you
did-- if instrumented code gets
a pointer that comes from here,
then those baggy bounds
with each particular pointer
will always be set to the
largest possible value, 231.
2 to the 31, right.
Which means that
it's going to be
impossible for baggy
bounds, entry of the code,
to think that you've done
an out of bound operation
with that pointer that's
coming from this uninstrumented
library.
So does that make sense?
So the idea is that
in instrumented code
we're always going to be
doing these comparisons
with the pointers, but if
we always set the bounds
entries for uninstrumented
pointer code 2 to the 31,
you can never have
a dereference error.
OK so that's basically how we
have this nice interoperability
between the entry of the
baggy bounds code in between
a noninstrumented off the
shelf legacy library's.
So putting it all together,
what does this all mean?
So, we have this
system here which
is nice because it doesn't make
the uninstrumented libraries
blow up, but one problem
is that we can't detect out
of bounds pointers
that were generated
in the uninstrumented
code, right.
Because we're never going to
set that high bit for example,
if that [INAUDIBLE]
pointer gets too big,
or gets too small or
anything like that.
So we actually can't
provide memory safety
for operations that take
place in uninstrumented code.
You also can't detect when
we pass an out of bounds
pointer from instrumented
code to uninstrumented code.
Something insane
could happen, right.
Because remember if you
had this out of bounds
pulled it from the
instrumented code
it has that high
bit set to 1, right.
So it looks like
it's super ginormous.
Now we know if we just kept
that code in instrumented code,
we might clear that
flag at some point
if it comes back in bounds.
But if we just pass
this ginormous address
to uninstrumented
code, then who knows,
it may try to dereference it,
it may do something crazy.
It may even bring that
pointer back in bounds,
but we would never
have an opportunity
to clear that high bit, right.
So you can come up--
you still may come up
with some inter-op
issues there, even if we
use this scheme over here.
OK, so that's essentially how
baggy bounds works on a 32--
you got a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so if you
have a instrumented coding
meets like allocated
memory, is it
using the same malloc that the
attributing code is using, or?
PROFESSOR: Yeah so
it's a bit subtle.
So like in this case
here, it's like very stark
what's going on, because there's
just two regions, one of which
is used by each set of things.
So it actually depends on
the if they use [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like that.
You can also imagine that like
in C++ [INAUDIBLE] for example,
you can define your
own allocator, right.
So it kind of
depends [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
input the same,
how does the allocator
know whether or not
to set 31 or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah so at the
lower level, typically the way
that these allocation
algorithms work,
is that you call unknown
system [INAUDIBLE] or something
like that, sort of
move a pointer up.
So you can imagine if you have
multiple allocators, all trying
to allocate memory,
they each have
their own chunk of memory
they reserve for themselves
basically, right.
So in real life it may be
more fragmented than this,
that's essentially on a
high level, how it works.
OK so this was a baggy
bounds on a 32-bit system.
So as you all know 64-bit
systems are the bees
knees these days, so
how does baggy bounds
work on those systems?
Well, in those systems
you can actually
get rid of the bounds table,
because we can actually
store some information about
the bounds, from the pointer
itself.
So imagine we're going to
look at a regular pointer
in a baggy bounds system.
So we can use it, like this.
So we can-- if the
pointer's in bounds,
we can basically just set
the first 21 bits to 0.
We can put the size
in these 5 bits here.
And once again this is
representing the log base 2
at the size here.
And then we have here,
in the remaining 38 bits,
just the regular address bits.
Now the reason why
this doesn't massively
curtail the address size
of the program you use,
is that a lot of
these high order bits,
the operating system
and-or the hardware,
doesn't let a application use,
for various reasons, right.
So as it turns out,
we're not dramatically
shrinking the amount of
[INAUDIBLE] application
you use in the system.
This is what a regular
pointer looks like.
Now what happens
when we only have
one of these out
of bounds pointers?
Well, in a 32-bit system
all we can do basically
is just set that high
order bit and you just
hope that thing never got
beyond a 1/2 a slot away
from it's base.
But now that we have all this
extra address space here,
you can actually put the out
of bounds offset directly
in this pointer.
So we can do
something like this.
So we can have 13 bits
here for the offset, right,
the out of bound offset.
How far away is this out of
bounds pointer, from the place
where it should be?
And then once again you
can put the actual size
of the referred object here.
This will be 0 once again.
And this will be the
real address base here.
And so this may be
reminiscent to you
of some type of fact
pointer representation,
but there's a
couple of advantages
here, now that we're
moving in the 64-bit world.
So first of all, you'll note
that these tag pointers,
these are the regular size
of a regular pointer, right.
Pointer's are still just 64-bits
wide in both of these setups.
So that's nice because
that means for example,
that means and rights to
that pointer are time.
Unlike in traditional
fat finger world,
where you actually have
to use multiple words
represent that fat pointer.
So that's nice.
And also note that we can
trivially ask these things,
uninstrumented
code, because they
work and are the same
size as regular pointers.
We can put these things
in structs for example,
and the size of those
structs won't change.
So this is very nice if we
can work in that 64-bit world.
So does that all make sense?
AUDIENCE: So why are there
eight 0-bits [INAUDIBLE]
pointer there?
Where like the 5 size
bits previously weren't.
PROFESSOR: So you're
talking about down here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
is there a reason
why we can't just
store a [INAUDIBLE]
if we're like six
0-bits there and had
more bits for the offset,
like why is the number 8?
PROFESSOR: So I think
so in some cases
there are certain line issues
that we have to work with.
The [INAUDIBLE] issue is to deal
with if the bits are higher.
I don't think, in
principle, there's
any reason why you
couldn't read some
of these things [INAUDIBLE].
Well there may be
some hard versions
that I'm not thinking
of right now,
but [INAUDIBLE] some of
these would have to 0
or otherwise the hardware's
going to cause a problem.
Any other questions?
OK so, next thing
are you wondering
is, can you still
launch a buffer
overflows in the
baggy bounds system,
obviously because I gave
you another paper to read,
so clearly this thing, this
doesn't solve all the problems,
right?
So one problem
you might run into
is that if you have
uninstrumented code once again,
we can't detect any problems
in uninstrumented code.
You could also encounter
memory vulnerabilities
that come about from the dynamic
memory allocation system.
So if you can remember
in the lecture
we looked at this weird
free malloc weird pointer
thing that took place.
Baggy bounds won't
necessarily prevent you
from some of that stuff.
We also discussed
last lecture, where
the fact that code
pointers do not have bounds
associated with them, right.
So now you have struct that
has a buffer at the bottom,
it has a function
pointer up top,
if you have a buffer overflow
in to that function pointer,
right.
Let's say that buffer
overflow is still
within the baggy bounds.
So you've overridden
that function pointer.
We would try to execute
that function pointer,
it could be pointed
at something for,
attack a control
piece of memory.
OK, and bounds won't
help with that,
because there's no bounds
associate with function
pointers.
And so in general, what are
the cost's of baggy bounds?
So there are essentially four.
So the first cost
is space, right.
So if you're using
a fat pointer,
obviously you've got to
make pointers bigger.
But if you're using the baggy
bounds system that we just
discussed, you've got to
store the bounds table, right.
And so the bounds table
has that slot size
which allows you to control
how big that bounds table is,
but still you may end up using
[INAUDIBLE] memory for that.
You've also got the CPU overhead
of doing all of the pointer
instrumentation, right.
So for every, or close to every
pointer thing that you do,
you got to check these bounds
using those shift operations
and things like that.
So that's going to
slow your program down.
There's also this problem
with false alarms, right.
So as we discussed,
it may be the case
that a program generates
out of bound pointers
but never tries to
dereference it, right.
Strictly speaking
that's not an issue.
The baggy bounds will
flag the creation
of those out of bounds
pointers, if they
get beyond a 1/2 a slot size,
at least in the 32-bit solution,
right.
And so what you'll see with
a lot of security tools,
is that false alarms really
reduce the likelihood
that people are going to
use your tools, right.
Because in practice
we would all hope
that we care about
security, but actually
what do people care about?
They want to be able to upload
their silly Facebook photos
and life things,
and they want to be
able to make things go
fast and stuff like that.
So you really want
your security tools
to probably have less
coverage of finding bugs,
but actually have
0 false alarms.
As opposed to catching all types
of security vulnerabilities,
but then maybe having
some false alarms
that are going to irritate
developers, or irritate users.
And the other costs that you
have for this is finally,
is that you need
compiler support, right.
Which can actually end
up being nontrivial,
because you have
to go in there, you
have to add all the
instrumentation,
crawl the pointer checks,
and so on ans so forth.
So those are basically the
cost of these bounds checking
approaches.
So that concludes the
discussion of baggy bounds.
And so now we can actually think
about a two other mitigation
strategies for buffer overflows.
They're actually much simpler
to explain and understand.
So one of these approaches is
called a non-executable memory.
And the basic idea is
that the paging hardware
is going to specify
3-bits for each page
that you have in memory, read,
write and execute, right.
Can the program read
that memory, write to it,
execute it.
The first 2-bits
are old, they've
been around for a while,
that last bit is actually
a fairly new construction.
And so the idea is
that you can actually
make the stack
non-executable, right.
So if you make the
stack non-executable
that means that the
adversary can't run code
just by pointing-- by
creating that shell code
and then sort of jumping to
someplace in that buffer.
And so what a lot of systems
do, is they actually specify
a policy like this.
So right exclusive or x,
which means that if you have
a particular page, you
can either write to it,
or you can treat it
as executable code,
but you cannot do both.
OK and so that once
again, is going
to prevent the
attacker from just
putting executable
code in the stack
and then going straight to it.
So this is-- should be pretty
straightforward, right.
So we've removed, at the
hardware level, this attack
vector of the attacker putting
executable code in the stack.
So what's nice about this?
Well potentially this
works without any changes
to the application, right.
This is all taken place
at the hardware level
and at the OS level,
with the OS just
making sure the pages are
protected with these bits, OK.
So that's very,
very nuts, right.
Because you don;t have to worry
about this compiler support
issue we had over here.
The other nice thing
is that, as I mentioned
in the last lecture,
the hardware's
always watching you, even
though the OS is not, right.
So these bits being
said over here,
you know they're
looked at and verified
for correctness at
every memory reference
that you make by the code.
That's a very nice
aspect of this too.
Now one disadvantage
of this system
though, is that it makes it
harder for an application
to dynamically generate code,
in benign or benevolent cases.
And the best example of
that is, the just-in-time
compilers that we discussed
from last lecture, right.
So how is it that
you can go to a web
page and your JavaScript
code executes fast.
It downloads that
JavaScript source,
it initially probably
starts just interpreting it,
but then at some
point it's going
to find some hot
path, some hot loop
and then it's going to
dynamically generate
x86 machine code and execute
that directly, right.
But to get that to work you have
to be able to dynamically write
code to a page.
So there's some ways you can
get around this for example,
you could imagine that the
just-in-time compiler initially
sets the write bit and then
it removes the write bit,
then it sets the execute bits.
There are some ways that
you can get around that,
but it can be a little
bit tricky sometimes.
On a higher level, that's how
non-executable memory works,
pretty easy to understand.
AUDIENCE: What is the
definition of like executable
instructions?
So if you change the
attenuator [INAUDIBLE]
it's not considered a
executable instruction.
PROFESSOR: Well basically no.
Can you set like the instruction
pointer register to that value.
In other words, can you-- if you
have a bunch of memory pages,
can you actually set EIP
there and actually start
executing code from that page.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so that
is nonexecutable memory.
And so another
technique you might
imagine for protecting
against a buffer overflows
is using a randomized
addresses or address spaces.
And so the observation
here is, that a lot
of the attacks that
we've discussed so far
use hard coded addresses, right.
And so if you think about
a lot of the attacks
you've been working on in
your lab, how does that work?
You open up the program
in GDB, you find out
the location of some things,
you may create some shell code
that actually has some hard
coded addresses in there,
right.
So the idea behind the
randomized address base
is simple.
Basically you want to make
it difficult for the attacker
to guess addresses.
So there's a couple
different ways
you could think about
doing this, right.
So one idea is that
you can imagine having
stack randomization, right.
So imagine that
from here to here,
this is the entire virtual
memory space of the program,
right.
As we described this
stuff to you so far,
basically the
stack always starts
with this particular place
up here, always goes down,
right, and the program codes
down here and the heap always
goes up here.
And all these seg-- all of these
segments, the stack, the heap,
and the program code, they all
start at a well known location.
So imagine for example, like
if my lecture notes here
are the stack.
You can imagine instead of
the stack always starting here
at this known location,
maybe you start it here,
maybe you start it here.
Somewhere else like that, right.
Similarly you can imagine that
maybe the program code which
used to always start
down here, maybe we
start it up here, or down here,
or something like that, right.
So the idea now is that
if you, the attacker,
control one of these
binary's, you can look in GDB
and figure out where
all these offsets are,
but they're not actually
going to help you figure out
where those offsets are
in the real code that's
running on the server, right.
So that's the basic idea behind
these randomized address spaces
there.
And so this takes
advantage of the fact
that a lot of the code
that you generate,
doesn't have to be loaded into
a specific place in memory,
right.
So unless you're writing like
a device driver, or something
like, that maybe is interacting
with some hardware that
requires this
particular address to be
belong in this particular buffer
so it can copy information in.
If you're not doing stuff
like that then typically
your codes going
to be relocatable.
So this approach will work very
nicely with that kind of stuff.
So once again the question
is, can you exploit this?
Obviously the
answer is still yes.
There's a couple different
ways you can do it
as we'll discuss later today
in the [INAUDIBLE] paper,
the attacker can actually
extract randomness, right.
And so in general that's
how you defeat all
these randomized approaches.
You make them unrandom,
by either finding out
the random seed that
the attacker was doing,
or by somehow leveraging the
fact that the attacker leaks
information about the randomized
locations of these things.
And another thing
that's interesting
is that for a lot of the
attacks we've discussed so far,
we've basically been using these
sort of hard coded addresses,
but note that the attacker
may not necessarily
care about jumping to
a specific address.
Or there's this attack
called a heap attack, which
is actually pretty hilarious if
you're a bad person, I suppose.
So the way that this
heap attack works
is, that the
attacker essentially
just starts dynamically
allocating a ton of shell code
and just stuffs it
randomly in memory, right.
This is particularly
effective if you're
using like a dynamically high
level language like JavaScript
let's say.
So the tag reader is
sitting in a tight loop
and just generate a bunch of
shell code strings, right.
And you just fill the heap
with all these shell code
strings, right.
Now the attacker maybe cannot
figure out where the exact
location is of each of
the shell code strings,
but if you've allocated 10s of
megabytes of shell code strings
and then just do a
random jump, right.
If you could somehow control
one of these ret pointers,
then hey, maybe you'll
land in shell code, right.
And one trick you
can actually use
is this thing called NOP sleds,
which is also pretty hilarious.
So imagine that if you have
a shell code string, then
it may not work out if
you jump to a random place
in that shell code
string, because it may not
set the attack up correctly.
But maybe this stuff that
your spewing to the heap,
is basically just a ton of NOPs
and then at the very, very end
you have the shell code, right.
This is actually
quite clever right,
because this means that now
you can actually goof up
the exact place where you jump.
If you jump into
another one of these NOP
things just go boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, then
you hit the shell code, right.
So it's like these are the
people that you probably
see on the team.
They're inventing these
types of things, right.
This is a problem.
So that's another way
to get around some
of this randomization
stuff, just
by making your codes
randomization resilient,
if that makes sense.
OK so that's basically
a discussion of some
of the types of
randomness you can use.
There's also some wacky ideas
that people have had too.
So now you know
that when you want
to make a system
call for example,
you use this syscall
libc function
and you basically pass
any unique number that
represents the system call
that you want to make, right.
So maybe four is seven and maybe
sleep is eight, or something
like that, right.
So what that means is that
if the attacker can somehow
figure out the address of
that syscall instruction
and jump to it somehow, he or
she can actually just supply
the system call number that they
want to invoke directly, right.
So you could imagine that
each time the program runs,
you actually create a dynamic
assignment of syscall numbers
to actual syscalls, right.
To make it harder for the
attacker to get stuff.
There's even some very
avant garde proposals
to change the hardware such
that the hardware actually
contains an xor key, that
is used to dynamically xor
instructions, right.
Imagine every time you
compile the program, all
of the instruction codes that's
the xor of some key, right.
That key is put into
that hardware register
when you initially
load the program
and then whenever you
execute an instruction,
the hardware
automatically xor's it,
before you continue executing
that instruction, right.
So what's nice about
that is, that now even
if the attacker can
generate the shell code,
the attacker doesn't
know that key, right.
So it's very difficult
for the attacker
to figure out what exactly
to put into memory.
AUDIENCE: But if
he can get the code
and he also instructions
he can xor it back
to the instruction [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR;Oh yeah.
This is always a
canonical problem, right.
So it's like what if
someone does this?
So that's exactly right.
So this is somewhat similar to
what happens in the BROP attack
where, essentially we've sort of
randomized where locations are,
but the attacker can
do probes, right.
And figure out what's going on.
So you can imagine too that for
example, if the attacker knows
some sub-sequence of
code that he's expects
to be in the binary,
you could imagine
just sort of trying to xor the
binary with that known code,
trying to extract the key.
And there's a lot
evil in the world,
so you're exactly
correct about that.
OK so that's essentially
the discussion
of all the randomization attacks
that I want to discuss today.
So one thing to
talk about before we
get to some of the return
oriented programming stuff,
is you might wonder which
ones of these defenses
are actually used in practice.
And so as it turns out,
both GCC and Visual Studio,
they both enable stack
canaries by default, right.
So that's very popular, that's
a very well known community.
If you look Linux
and Windows they
can also do things like
non-executable memory.
They can also do things like
randomize the address space, so
that's also [INAUDIBLE].
The baggy bounds stuff
however, is not as popular.
And that's because of
some of these costs
that we talked about
over here, in terms
of memory overhead, CPU, the
false alarms, and so on ans
so forth.
So that's basically a survey
of the state of the art,
in trying to prevent
these buffer overflows.
So now we're going to talk about
this return oriented programing
stuff.
So what I'm described to
you so far today in terms
of the address space
randomization and the data
execution prevention,
that's the-- the
read, write and execute
that I just described.
Those things are actually
very, very powerful, right.
Because the randomization
prevents the attacker
from actually understanding
where our hard coded addresses
are.
And the data
execution prevention
says, even if you can put
shell code into the stack,
then the attacker
can't just jump to it
and execute it, right.
So at its space,
that seems like,
man you've really
made a lot of progress
for stopping these attackers,
but of course there
are these hackers out there who
spend all their time thinking
about how to ruin our lives.
So what's the insight behind
return oriented programming?
The insight is that, what
if instead of the attacker
being able to generate just
new code at attack time, what
if the attacker could
string together preexisting
pieces of code and then string
them together in deviant ways,
right?
And we know that the program
contains a ton of code already,
right.
So hopefully, or unhopefully,
depending on which side of this
you're on.
If you can find enough
interesting code snippets,
you can string them
together to basically form
like this Turing
complete language, where
the attacker can essentially
do whatever the attacker wants
to do.
So that's the insight behind
return oriented programming.
So understand how this works.
Let's look at a very simple
example that will initially
start off very familiar, right.
But then it's very quickly
going to descend into madness.
So let's say that we have
the following program.
So we have some program-- sorry,
some function and conveniently
for the attacker, it has this
nice function here called
run shell.
So this is just
going to call system,
it's going to execute bin
slash bash and then be done.
And then we've got the canonical
buffer overflow process
or sorry, function down
here, basically this thing
is going to declare a
buffer, and then it's
going to use one of
these unsafe functions
to fill in bytes in the buffer.
OK so, we know that this
can be overflowing OK,
this is old news.
Now what's interesting is that
we have this function up here,
run shell, but it
doesn't quite seem
to be accessed in some direct
way based on this buffer
overflow.
So how can the attacker invoke
this run shell command here?
Well the attack may
do a couple things.
So first of all, the attacker
can disassemble the program,
run GDB, find out the address
of this thing in the executable,
right.
So you all should be very
familiar with doing those kinds
of things through the lab.
That's the first thing
the attacker can do.
And then during the
buffer overflow,
the attacker can essentially
take that address,
put it in the buffer
overflow that's generated
and make sure that the
function returns to run shell.
So just to make that clear,
let's draw that over here.
So, you have a setup
that looks something
like this at the bottom,
we have the buffer,
that's being overflowed.
And then up here, we have
the save the break pointer,
up here we have the return
address, for process message.
So remember that the new stack
pointer will be here initially,
when we start
executing the function.
This is the new
break pointer, this
is what the stack
pointer used to be.
And then we've got some
break pointer up here,
for the previous frame.
OK, so this should
look pretty familiar.
So basically, in the
attack, like I said,
we've used GDB to
figure out what
the address is of run shell.
So in the buffer overflow,
we can essentially just
put the address of run
shell right here, right.
So this is a actually pretty
straightforward extension
of what we already
know how to do, right.
So basically it's saying,
if we conveniently
have a command
that runs a shell,
if we can disassemble
the binary, figure out
where that address is, we can
just put that in this overflow
array that we have here.
So that should be
pretty straightforward.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So, this was a very
childish example,
because the programmer
for some crazy reason
has put this low
hanging fruit here.
So as an attacker this is like
Christmas coming early, right.
Now it may not be the case
that you have something
as delightful as this.
So what you could have instead,
is something like this.
So let's say that instead
of this thing being called
run shell, we call it
run boring and then
maybe this thing just executes
bin slash OS let's say.
But let's say that everything
is not completely lost,
because we actually
have a string up here
that conveniently gives
us the path of that.
So what's interesting about
this is, that we can disassemble
the program, find the
location of run boring,
but as an attacker,
who wants to run an OS?
Right, that's no fun
But we do actually
have a string in memory that
points to the path of the shell
and actually we also know
something interesting too.
Which is that even though the
program isn't calling system
with the argument that we want,
it is calling system somehow.
So we know that
system must be getting
linked into this
program somehow, right.
So we can actually
leverage those two things,
to actually call system
with this argument here.
So the first thing that we
do, is we can go into GDB
and we can actually
figure out where
this thing is located in the
process binary image, right.
So you just go to GDB, just
type in basically print system
and I'll give you
some information
about the offset of that OK.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
You can also do the same
thing with bash path.
Right, you just use
GDB to figure out
where this thing lives.
It's statically
declared string, right.
So you'd be able to find
out where that lives.
And so once you've
done that, now you
got to do something a
little bit different, right.
Because now we actually
have to figure out somehow,
how to invoke system with
an argument of our choosing,
right.
And so the way that we do
that is by essentially faking
a calling frame for system.
OK, so remember that
a frame is the thing
that the compiler
and the hardware
work together to use to
implement the call stack,
right.
So here's basically
what we want to do.
We want to set up something
like this on the stack, right.
So basically we're
going to fake what
system would expect
to be on the stack,
but right before it
actually executes its code.
So up here we had the
argument of the system,
this is the string that we
actually want to execute.
And then down here, this is
where system should return to,
when it's done.
Right, so this is what system
expects the stack to look like,
right before it
starts execution.
It's going to say this is where
I should go when I'm finished,
this is the thing I should
consume as my argument, right.
In the past we've been
assuming that there
were no arguments when
you pass the functions,
but now this is a little
bit different, right.
So basically we
just have to ensure
that this thing is in that
overflow code that we create,
right.
We just have to make
sure this fake calling
frame is in that array.
So basically the
way this will work
is, we will do the following.
So once again remember
the overflow goes up here.
So first, we're going to put
the address of system here.
And then here, we're going
to put just some junk return
address.
Right, this is
where system's going
to return after it's finished.
For the purposes
of the discussion
now, we don't care
what this does,
we'll just make this be just
some random set of bytes.
And then up here,
we're actually going
to put the address
of bash path, right.
So what's going
to happen now when
we do this buffer in overflow?
So what's going to happen is
that, process message is going
to finish, it's
going to say, OK hey,
here's where I should
return to, right.
And then it's going to
pop the stack, right,
and now the system code
is executing, right.
The system code now sees
that fake call frame
that we created, right.
As far as system is
concerned, nothing chicanerous
has taken place, right.
System will say, aha
here's the argument
that I want to execute,
it's bin slash bash,
it's going to execute it
and voila, the attacker
has a shell, right.
So does this make sense?
So basically what we've
done is, we've now
taken advantage of knowledge
of the calling convention,
for the platform to
create fake stack frames,
or fake calling
frames I should say.
And using those
fake calling frames,
we can actually execute any
function that is already linked
and defined in the application.
Does that make sense?
OK so, another question
you might have is,
what if this string wasn't
actually in the program?
Now to be clear, this
string is almost certainly
in the program.
So that's one funny
thing about security,
there's just all kinds of fun
strings that are laying around,
you can just go to
town all day long.
Well let's suppose we
live in bizarro world
and like this string
is not in the program.
So does anyone have
any ideas about what
we could do to get that
string to be in the program?
AUDIENCE: We can put the
string on the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR; Yes exactly,
don't trust that man.
That's what you can do, exactly.
So, what you can do
is actually for here,
have the address of bash path,
actually point here, right.
And then you'd put-- up here
you would put slash B-I-N
slash P-A-T slash 0.
So that's how you
can get around-- I
think I got that math right,
because each one of these
is 4 bytes.
But anyway, so you have the
pointer go up here and then
boom, you're done.
So now you can actually
conjure up arguments
just by putting them
in the shell code.
Pretty horrifying.
So this is all building up
towards the full BROP attack,
right.
But before you can mention
the full BROP attack,
you've got to
understand how you just
chain together these
preexisting things in the code.
So one thing to note is that
when I'm setting up this return
address here, I just said,
eh just put some junk here,
it doesn't really matter,
we just want to get a shell.
But if you're the attacker,
you could actually
set this return
address to something
that's actually useful, right.
And if you did that, you
could actually string together
several functions, several
function indications in a row,
right.
That's actually very,
very powerful, right.
Because in particular,
if we literally just
set this return
address to jump, I
mean it may be that
when we ret from it,
like the program crashes on
it, maybe we don't want that,
right.
So can actually start
chaining some of these things
to do interesting stuff.
So let's say that our goal is
that we want to call system
an arbitrary number of times.
We don't just want
to do it one time,
we're going to it a
arbitrary number of times.
So how can we do that?
Well, we're going to use
two pieces of information
that we already know
how to get, right.
We already know how to get
the address of system, right.
We just look in GDB and find it.
We also know how to find
the address of that string,
bin flash bash.
Now to actually make this
attack work using multiple calls
to system, we're going to
have to use gadgets, right.
This is getting us
closer to what's
taking place in the BROP paper.
So what we need to do
now, is find the address
of these two Op codes.
Right, so what is this, so this
is pop in EAX, so what does
this do?
This just takes the
top of the stack
and then it puts it
into the EAX register.
And what is the ret
instruction going to do?
It just pops the
top of the stack
and then puts it into
EIP, instruction pointer.
OK, so this is what's
known as a gadget, right.
This is like a small set
of assembly instructions
that the attacker can use
to build these larger more
grandiose attacks.
OK, So how can we find
this gadget, right.
There's actually like
some off the shelf tools
that hackers use to
find these things,
it's not hard to get
the binary, right.
Essentially just
do a [INAUDIBLE]
for these types
of things, right.
So it's just as easy to
find one of these gadgets,
assuming that you've
got a copy of the binary
and we're not worried
about randomization yet.
It's very easy to
find these things.
Just like it's very easy to find
the address of system and stuff
like that.
So if we've got one
of these gadgets,
what can we use
this gadget to do?
Well of course the
answer is evil.
So, what we can do
is the following.
Let's say that we
changed the stack
so that it looks like this.
So the exploit goes this way.
And so let's say, we do this.
So the first thing
we're going to put here
is the address of system.
And the thing we're
going to put up here,
is the address of
the pop ret gadget.
Then up here, we're going to
put the address of bash path
and then we're going
to repeat this pattern.
So we're going to put
the address of system,
the address of the
pop ret gadget,
and then the address
of bash path.
OK, so what's going
to happen here now?
Now this is going
to be a bit tricky,
and these lecture
notes are going
to be up on the
web, so you may just
want to listen to
what's happening,
but this-- when I first
understood this, this
was like understanding that
Santa Claus wasn't real right.
So what will happen
is-- and by the way,
Santa Claus isn't real, I hope
I didn't ruin it for everyone.
So what's going to happen?
So [INAUDIBLE] is what
puts this in memory.
So we're going to
start here, OK.
So what's going to happen?
We're going to return to
system, the ret instruction
is going to pop an
entry off the stack, now
the top of the
stack pointers here.
OK, so system is going to
find its argument here,
it's going to execute the shell.
Then it's going to finish
and return to whatever's
here, which is the pop gadget.
In executing that
return, we change
the top of the stack
pointer to be here.
OK, now we are in
the pop ret gadget.
OK, so what is that pop
ret gadget going to do?
It's going to pop what's on
the stack, which is this, OK.
So now the top of
the stack is here.
Then we're now in
the ret instruction
from the pop ret gadget.
What's this going to do?
Aha, it's going to call
system again, right.
So once again the ret is going
to pop this off this stack,
we are now in system.
Top of the stack
is here, system is
going-- this will trigger
calling frame, the system.
System takes the bash
path argument here.
OK, and then it is
going to ret, right.
Where's it going to ret to?
The pop ret gadget again.
So the ret pops
the stack, we are
now in the pop ret gadget,
the ret gadget-- sorry,
the pop ret gadget is going to
pop this, so on and so forth.
OK?
So clearly we can
chain this sequence
to execute an arbitrary
number of things, right.
And so this in
essence is starting
to get to the core of what
return oriented programming is.
Note that we have not executed
anything in the stack, right.
This is what has allowed us to
get beyond those data execution
prevention bits, right.
Nothing's been executed here.
We're just sort of jumping
to things in unexpected ways
to do what we want to do.
OK so this is actually
very, very, very, clever.
And so what's interesting
is that at a high level
you can think about us, we've
now defined this new model
for computation, right.
So in a traditional,
non-malicious program,
you have the
instruction pointer that
points to some linear
sequence of instructions.
And you increment the
instruction pointer
to figure out what's
the next thing to do.
In essence, what return
oriented programing does is,
it uses the stack pointer
as the instruction pointer.
Right, so as we move
the stack pointer,
we're pointing to like
other blocks of code
that we're going to execute.
And then at the
end of the gadget,
you return back to
the stack pointer
which is then going to tell
us the next block of code
to execute.
OK so that does that make sense?
So that's basically how you
can avoid the data execution
prevention stuff.
That's how you can
get around having
this no execute bit on pages.
So the next thing that
we might want to do
is defeat stack canaries.
So if you remember, this
canary was this value
that we were going to
place on the stack, right.
So you can imagine
the canary would
go right here for
example, or right here,
and it would prevent someone
from overriding the return
address, without also
overwriting the canary.
With the intuition being that
before the system actually
jumps to the ret
address, it can check
to see if the canary
has been changed
in a way that's incorrect.
So that's how the
canary works, but can we
get around the canary?
Can we guess the canary somehow?
Well we can actually, if
we make a few assumptions
about how the system works.
So, how do we defeat
those canaries?
So the first thing that we want
to assume is, that the server,
it has to have a buffer
overflow vulnerability.
The second thing that
we're going to assume,
is that the server is going
to crash and respond, just
restart, if we set the
canary value to a bad one.
And the third thing that
we're going to assume
is that, after the restart,
that the canary and any address
space randomization that you're
doing, is not rerandomized.
Right, so what that
means is that, we're
going to assume that if we can
somehow crash the server, then
when the server restarts,
it's going to have
the same value for the canary.
And it's going to have the same
locations for all the quote
unquote "randomized" stack,
heap and code information
that it has.
So you might wonder why
would this be the case?
Why would it be that when
the server comes back
it doesn't have new
locations for things?
The reason is because
a lot of servers
are written to use fork,
to create new processes.
And if you remember,
fork actually
inherits-- the child
inherits the address
space of the address space
layout right of the parent,
right.
This is copy on write pages
that change stuff as the child
updates things, but
if you use fork here,
instead of execing
a whole new process,
any time that parent server
process forms new children,
those children will have the
same values of the canary
in the address base, OK.
So these are the
assumptions that we're
going to make to try to
defeat these canaries here.
So how can we defeat the canary?
Well the attack is actually
fairly straightforward.
So imagine that the stack
is going up this way, right.
Imagine you got the
buffer overflow here,
then imagine that the
canary is up here, right.
And the canary actually
has multiple bytes, right.
So what you can
actually do is, you
can probe those bytes one by
one and start guessing values
of what those bytes are, right.
So let's say that-- so the
canary looks like this.
Here's the overflowing
buffer, and you want
to guess what these bytes are.
So the first thing
that you guess
is you take your overflow,
just to this first byte
of the canary and you
say, hey, is that byte 0?
You write a 0 there,
with your overflow.
You're either correct
or you're incorrect.
If you are incorrect, then the
server's going to crash, right.
If you are correct you
say, aha I actually
know the first byte of
the canary now, right.
Then you start guessing here.
You say, are you 0?
Probably not, it's
going to crash.
Are you one?
And maybe not, it's
going to crash.
Are you two?
Aha, it doesn't crash, right.
So now you've actually found
the value of that second canary
byte, right.
As you can imagine,
you step up this way,
and you eventually find all
the values for the canary.
So once again we're taking
advantage of the fact,
that crashes are a signal
to you, the attacker,
that you've actually done
something wrong, right.
And the server is staying
up, in other words,
that socket connection's
staying open, is
a signal to you, the
attacker, that you've
done something right.
AUDIENCE: Maybe I mentioned
something basic here
like why do you-- if you
know how long the canary is,
can you just infect directly?
Skip that buffer
and overflow those--
the one path there the canary?
So like [INAUDIBLE] say you can
like [INAUDIBLE] the canary--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah you
can't-- so that's right
if you-- so if you in fact
know the exact location
of the canary, right.
That can sometimes
allow you to skip
some of these attacks totally.
Because then you
can just directly
write to the return
address, let's say,
as opposed to doing some of
this buffer overflow nonsense.
But in general, if there's
some level of randomization
here, if you don't quite know
where the stack is for example,
then it's tricky
to do that, right.
So basically the way
that the attack proceeds
is that you don't quite
know what's happening,
and so you just very slowly
creep your way up memory,
down the stack, to figure
out where these things are.
AUDIENCE: Can the
server instead of
crashing when it
finds strong canaries,
keep the socket open and
[INAUDIBLE] deprocess
and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so we'll
discuss at the end of lecture
some of the defenses you
can have against this,
but one very, abstractly
speaking civil defense,
is that when the
program crashes,
you catch the segfault
using a signal handler,
do not deduce you're
own code by the way.
But you can do this, right.
You catch that segfault
and then the signal handler
just keeps that
process alive for a bit
and that will trick the
attack into thinking that,
oh I won't get that signal
back, in other words.
OK so that's
basically how you can
guess the value for the canary.
And note that you can
actually use this attack
to sort of figure out
arbitrary values that
are low in the stack, right.
Just by iteratively guessing
for each byte what it is,
and then using that
crash indication
as a signal of whether you're
guess was correct or not.
So that's basically
how you can defeat
these randomized
canaries, assuming
that after the server restarts,
those things are not changed.
And so we've also
shown how you can
use the gadgets
to string together
these more elaborate attacks.
So what we're going
to look at next
is a way that you can use all
these techniques to defeat
data execution prevention,
address-based randomization
and canaries on a
production system.
Now what we're
going to do now is,
we're actually going
to start looking
at 64-bit architectures instead
of 32-bit architectures.
As it turns out for
randomization purposes,
64-bit architectures
actually give you
a lot more randomness to protect
yourself against the attacker.
So looking at attacks
is much more interesting
on those systems.
So that's also the type
of architecture that's
discussed in the BROP paper.
They talk about 64-bit machines.
So from now on,
assume that we're
going to talk about the
64-bit architectures.
For the purposes
of this discussion,
the only difference
between a 32-bit machine
and a 64-bit machine, is
that on a 32-bit machine,
the arguments are passed
on the stack, right.
So here for example, this
is like a 32-bit machine
we were assuming, so
for example, bash path
will pass on the stack.
On a 64-bit machine,
the arguments
are passed in registers instead.
OK so like when a
function starts execution,
it's going to look
in certain registers
to find where the arguments are.
OK, make sense?
All right.
So start up here.
All right, so now we get to
the point of today's paper.
Which is the blind return
oriented programming.
So what's the first
thing you want to do,
if you want to engage in
BROP for fun or profit?
So the first thing
you have to do
is, you have to find what
they call a stop gadget.
Now a stop gadget-- and remember
that when we say gadget,
we essentially mean,
return addresses, right.
A gadget is identified
by the return address,
by the start address of that
sequence of instructions
that we want to jump to, right.
So what is a stop gadget?
So a stop gadget is
essentially a return address
to someplace in the code,
but if you jump to it,
you're going to
pause the program,
but you're not
going to crash it.
OK, so that's why it's
called a stop gadget.
Now what might that
stop gadget be?
You might jump to someplace
in the code that then calls
via the sleep system call
for example, or does pause,
or something like that.
Or maybe somehow the program
gets stuck in an infinite loop
if you jump to that place.
Doesn't really matter
why the stop's happening,
but you could imagine
several scenarios which would
cause that stop to take place.
So why is this useful?
Well once the
attacker has managed
to defeat the canaries using
that iterative guessing
technique I showed
you, he can start
to overwrite this return
address and start probing
for these stop gadgets, right.
And so note that
most of the random
addresses you might
put there, they'll
probably crash
the server, right.
Once again, that's the
message to you, the attacker,
that's an indication that what
you found is not a stop gadget,
right.
Because when the server
crashes your sockets--
your socket
connection is closed.
You as an attacker
know, OK that must not
have been a stop gadget.
Where if you guess something
and then you-- that socket still
stays open for
awhile, you think,
aha I found that stop gadget.
So that's the basic
idea behind step one.
You got to find
that stop gadget.
Now step two, is
that you want to find
gadgets that pop stack entries.
And so you basically have to
use this sequence of carefully
crafted instructions
to figure out
when we've got one of
these stack gadgets.
So this sequence
is going to consist
of a probe address, a stop
address, and a crash address.
So the probe
address is the thing
that we're going to
put in the stack.
This is going to be the address
of a potential stack popping
gadget.
This stop gadget is going to
be what we found in step one.
So this is an address
of the stop gadget.
And then the crash
gadget is just
going to be the address
of nonexecutable code.
So for example, you
could just set this
to, just the
address zero, right.
If you do a ret to this and
then try to execute code there,
this is going to
crash your program.
So we can basically use
these types of addresses
to find out where these
stack popping gadgets are.
So here's a simple example.
So let's write this over here.
So let's say we have these two
different examples of a probe,
a trap, and then a stop, right.
So let's assume that
we have down here,
we're going to probe
at some address,
doesn't really matter,
starts with a four,
ends with an eight.
That doesn't matter.
Over here, let's say that
we look at the address
that, let's say starts
in a four ends in a C.
So we're saying,
we're hypothesizing,
that maybe one of
these two addresses
is going to be one of these
stack popping gadgets.
And then let's say
that the trap up here,
like I said this is just
going to be address zero,
and then let's assume that we
found some preexisting stop
gadget, some addresses start
the [INAUDIBLE] doesn't really
matter.
And remember this stop gadget,
like maybe this address,
points to code that does
something like sleep 10,
or something like that, right.
So when I say that we're
going to test these sequences,
this is the stuff that we're
going to push onto the stack,
right.
So similar to over there, when
we were pushing these gadgets
onto the stack,
this is the stuff
that we're going to
push onto the stack,
and we're going to see
what happens, right.
Now let's say that,
this code here, points
to the following sequence.
We're going to pop some
register, let's say racks,
and then we're going to return.
So what's going to happen here?
Well so when the system
jumps this address,
the stack pointer's
going to move here, OK.
Now we're in the middle
of this gadget, right.
What's the gadget going to do?
It's going to pop racks, OK.
Top of stack pointer's
now here, and it's
going to return to whatever's
the top of the stack which
is the stop gap, right.
So in this case this
gadget gets us to here,
and the attacker
can tell that this
is-- this probe address belong
to one of these pop stacking
things, right.
Because the client
connection stays open.
Now let's say that
this gadget here,
pointed to something
like the following.
Maybe it just does like
an xor, for example.
So it's just going to xor
some registers and then it's
going to ret.
So what happens if we try
to jump to this gadget?
Right, note that this does not
pop anything off the stack, OK.
It just changes the
contents of registers.
So what's going to happen?
So we're going to
be here, we're going
to jump to the address
of this gadget,
stack pointer goes here, OK.
We're going to xor
these two things, right.
Stack pointer's not
going to change.
Then we're going to return to
whatever the top of the stack
is, which is 0, 0.
This is going to crash.
OK, the client connection to
the server is going to close,
and as a result, the attacker
knows that this is not
a stack popping gadget.
So does that all make sense?
And so you can also
imagine that you can--
by coming with more
baroque series of traps
and stop gadgets
and stuff like that,
you can find things that
for example, pop two things
off the stack, right.
You can just put another one
of these trap instructions
there, right.
And so then unless
the-- unless this gadget
pops two things
off, you're going
to end up in one of these
traps and your code execution
is going to blow up, right.
And so in the paper they discuss
like this thing called the BROP
gadget, which is sort
of like hilariously
complex if you're not used
to returning to programming.
What I'll show you today
is you can actually
just use these very
simple pop gadgets
to launch the same attack.
Then hopefully after
you understand this,
the BROP gadget will
make more sense.
But does everyone
understand how we can probe
for these little gadgets here?
OK.
So, once you've got these
gadgets, what do you know?
Well you found the location
of code snippets that
allow you to pop stuff up,
one thing off the stack.
Precisely one thing
off the stack,
but you don't actually
know into what register
they're popping it into.
You just know that they're
getting popped off, right.
And you actually
need to know what
register these gadgets
are popping stuff
into, because remember,
on a 64-bit architecture,
the registers control where the
arguments are to this function
that you want to invoke, right.
So the ultimate goal
to keep in mind,
is that we want to be able
to create some gadgets that
allow us to pop values
that we put on the stack
into certain registers,
and eventually we're
going to call a system
call that's going to allow
us to do something evil.
OK, so the next thing
that we need to do
is determine which
registers-- so determine which
registers the pop gadgets use.
So how are we going to do that?
Well basically we can take
advantage of the pause system
call.
OK, so the pause system call,
it takes no arguments, right.
And that means that it ignores
everything in the registers.
OK.
And essentially, to find
the pause instruction what
we can do is, we can chain
all of these pop gadgets
in such a way, that we put
all of them on the stack,
in between each one of them
we put the syscall number
for pause, and then we
see if we can actually
get the program to hang.
Let me give you a
concrete example of that.
So we'll do something like this.
So here for the return address,
we'll put the following.
So let's say we have one
gadget that pops RDI register,
then does a ret.
And then up here we'll put
the syscall number for pause.
And then let's say that we have
another gadget that we found,
that does a pop into a different
register, let's say RSI.
And then we'll put the
system call number for pause
up here again.
And we do this for all the
gadgets that we've found
and then eventually we put
the guest address for pause,
or sorry for syscall, excuse me.
Once again, remember how you
invoke these system calls.
So you basically have to put
the number of the system call
into the RAX register, then
you invoke this libc function
syscall which is then going to
execute the requested system
call, OK.
So what's going to happen
when we execute this code?
Right, so we're
going to come here,
we're going to jump to the
address of this gadget,
and note that as an
attacker, all that we know
is that this gadget here
pops something off the stack.
We don't know what the
register is yet, right.
Put it here just to
make the [INAUDIBLE],
but the attacker
doesn't know yet, right.
So if you jump-- or
sorry the-- we jump
to the gadget, the
stack corners now here,
what's it going to do?
It's going to pop this
syscall number for pause,
into some register the
attacker doesn't know,
and then we're going to continue
to go up this chain and so
on and so forth.
And what you'll see is that
each one of these gadgets, one
of them hopefully will
pop the system call
number into the
appropriate RAX register.
So that by the time
we get up to here,
I mean we basically
polluted all the registers,
with the system call number,
but hopefully just one of them
has to be correct, right.
Because if one of our gadgets
does this, then by the time
we ret to here,
we'll get a pause.
Once again, that pause acts as
a signal to the attacker, OK.
Because if this guest
address was wrong,
then probably the program's
going to crash, right.
So what does this phase
of the attack let us do?
Well we still don't
know which gadgets
pop into which registers,
but we know that one of them
is popped into RAX, which is
the one we want to control.
And for sure we know the
address of syscall, right.
Because we were able to
induce the pause, right.
So once we've done that, right.
Once we know for sure
where this thing is,
the address for syscall,
then we can actually just
try the gadgets
one by one, right.
And see which one of
them is actually going
to induce the pause, right.
So in other words, cut all
the middleman here, let's
have a stack it looks like this,
and then you just immediately
jump to syscall.
Did that cause the
pause or did it crash?
If it crashed, OK
we know this gadget,
it pops to RDI for example.
OK, get rid of that one, right.
Try the next gadget, right.
Put the guest address-- put the,
well it's not guest anymore,
put the real address
for syscall up here.
Were we able to
pause the program?
Yes?
Aha, so we know that pop
gadget must pop into RAX.
So does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: So the way to guess
the address for system call
is just blind transfer?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
there-- so in the paper,
they go into some
optimizations about how
you can work in a PLT and
all that kind of stuff.
Like I said, I think it's easier
to ignore that for a second,
and just look toward
the simpler thing
first, but yeah in a simple
attack that I'm describing,
yeah you just put
some address up here
and you just see if you pause.
So does that all make sense?
OK so at the end of
this we actually know
the location of syscall.
We know the location
of the instruction
that does the pop into RAX.
Now you can imagine that we
also need gadgets that pop
into some other registers too.
Suffice to say, you can
do similar tests, right.
So instead of like pushing a
system call number for pause,
push it for some
other command that
now takes in all arguments in
RAX and RDI for example, right.
Do the same type of test, right.
So basically you can
leverage the fact
that for any particular
set of registers
that you want to
be able to control,
there's some system
call that will give you
a signal as an attacker,
that allow you to figure out
whether you successfully
broke it or not.
Right, so at the
end of this phase,
you basically have
the address of syscall
and the address of
a bunch of gadgets
which allow you to pop
into arbitrary registers.
OK and so now let's
see so, step 4
is going to be to invoke write.
Step 4 is invoke the
write system call.
So to invoke write, we need
to have the following gadgets.
You need to be able to pop RDI.
We need to be able to pop RSI.
We need to be able to pop RDX,
pop racks, and then invoke
syscall, right.
So as it turns out,
what are these registers
being used for by system call?
So this is the socket, or more
generally, the file descriptor
that you're going
to pass into write.
This is the buffer.
This is the length
of that buffer.
This is the syscall number.
And it is called syscall.
Right, so if we found
all these gadgets,
then we can actually
now control the values
that are put into
those arguments, that
put in those registers,
because we just pushed them
on the stack, right.
And so for example, what's
the socket going to be?
For once you're going to have
to do a little guessing here,
right.
can take advantage of the
fact that Linux restricts
the number of simultaneous
open file connections,
for a file that's
going to be 2024.
And also it's supposed to
be the lowest one available.
So we do a little bit of
guessing here and figure out
what that socket
is, put it in there.
Now interestingly,
what are we going
to pass into the buff pointer?
Right, we're actually
going to use the text
segment of the program.
We're actually going to pass in
that the pointer to somewhere
in the code of the program.
So what's that going
to allow us to do?
That's going to allows us to
read the binary, out of memory,
using the right call
to the client socket.
So that the attacker can
then take that binary,
analyze it offline, right.
Just use GDB, or
whatever, to figure out
where everything is located.
The attacker knows that now,
every time the server crashes,
it's going to have the same
randomized set of things in it.
So now, once the attacker can
find out addresses and offsets
for stuff, now the
attacker can directly
attack those gadgets, right.
Directly attack other
vulnerabilities,
figure out how to open up a
shell, so on and so forth.
So in other words,
at the point you
exfiltrated the binary to the
attacker, you basically lost.
Right, so this is essentially
how the BROP attack works.
Like I said, in
the paper, there's
a bunch of optimization,
but really you
need to understand this
stuff, the basic stuff,
before that optimization
will start to make sense.
And so we can talk about the
optimization with me offline
if you want, or after class.
But to suffice it
to say, this is
the basics of how you
launch that BROP attack.
You've got to find
the stop gadget,
find those gadgets
that pop stack entries.
Figure out which
of those registers
those gadgets pop
into, and find out
how to figure out where
syscall is, and then invoke
write by accumulating
all that knowledge.
So very quickly, how do
you defend against BROP?
Well the most obvious
thing is you've
got to rerandomize, right.
So the fact that
crashed servers do not
respawn, rerandomize
versions of themselves,
that allows the crash to
act as a signal that let's
the attacker test
various hypotheses
about how the programs working.
So one simple defense
is to make sure
that you do exec when you spawn
your process, instead of fork,
right.
Because when you exec the
process, you create totally new
randomized layout space,
at least on Linux, right.
So on Linux, when you compile
with this PIE, the Position
Independent Executable
flag, you only
get that randomized
address space
that's new if you use exec.
So another event you can
use is just use Windows,
because Windows
basically does not
have a fork equivalent, right.
So hooray for us.
So that means that
on Windows, whenever
you spawn that new
server, it's always
going to have a new
randomized address space.
I think someone over here
mentioned something like,
what would happen
if for example,
when the server crashed,
it didn't actually
close the connection?
Right, so you can
imagine one thing
that when a crash takes place,
we somehow catch that fault
and then we keep that connection
open for a little while
to confuse the attacker
and remove that signal,
that something's gone amiss.
So that's something
you definitely do.
What's hilarious about that
is, that now your BROP attack
turns into a denial
of service attack.
Because now you just got
all the potential zombie
processes that are sitting
around, they segfaulted.
They're useless in
society, but you
can't let them go, because
otherwise you're going
to delete this information.
Another thing you
might think about to,
is you could do bounds
checking, right.
We just talked a bunch
about that, right.
But in the paper, they
casually dismiss this
as saying it has
up to 2x overhead,
so nobody's going to do that,
but you could in fact do that.
So that's basically
how BROP works.
As for the homework
question, the homework
questions a bit subtle, because
the homework question says,
what if you use a hash of
the current time, right?
Get time of day when you
restarted the program.
Is that sufficient to
prevent this type of attack?
Well note that, hashing
does not magically
provide you bits of entropy
if the input to the hash
is easily guessable, right.
If I know that you're only
going to hash one or two things,
it doesn't matter if I have
like some a jillion bit hash.
Doesn't matter.
So I can just guess one of those
two values and see what is.
So the thing to note is
that get time of day,
actually has much less
entropy than you might think.
Particularly because the
attacker can actually
check what time he or she is
launching the attack, right.
So that's going to actually
remove a bunch of entropy
from that calculation, right.
So there's some
subtleties there.
What's the server skew in
terms of clock or the client
and so on and so forth.
The long story short, using
a guessable base value,
even with guessable
just inside of a range,
is super useful for
the attacker, right.
Particularly
because the attack--
we can start subverting a
bunch of servers in parallel
and know that all
of them should have
fairly similar values, right.
This is a high order
of bits, right.
So long story
short, the answer is
that, it's literally better
than nothing to randomize,
if you use get time of day, but
it doesn't actually provide you
as much security as you think.
And the other lesson too
is, that just because you
hash something
right, that doesn't
matter if you're not actually
using that hash in a smart way.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, still when I
did the calculations that some
[INAUDIBLE] it seems
like maybe to be
able to get the offset
that the [INAUDIBLE]
your [INAUDIBLE]
start the process
to within like 48 milliseconds?
PROFESSOR: Yes and
getting the timing right
depends on a bunch of
different things, right.
But you could take
advantage of the fact
that the attacker can open
up a bunch of connections
in parallel, and
leverage the fact
that even if the initial
guess a little bit off,
you can still launch
multiple guesses on what
should be very
similar canary values,
and do that attack in parallel.
But you're right, there's
tricky time and issues.